I did it post the other day on on
Twitter I'll just I'll just read it out
it's it says uh Western culture is a
scam for men this got 21 000 likes on it
um you get up early pay for a house you
hardly live in it you don't own the land
it sits on you pay a mortgage to a bank
that lent you pretend money made out of
thin air you pay interest on they didn't
even have on deposit in a vault you
drive a car that is primarily used to
get to and from work usually on
congested and broken roads your tax
money never seems to fix you pay 30 to
50 percent in income tax to the
government for a job a job designed to
keep you just over broke while the
government spends your money on programs
you generally don't agree with to buy
stuff with sales tax with money you've
already paid income taxes on to impress
people we don't even like with things we
generally don't even care about
and if you do well with your Investments
with income you've already been taxed on
you pay more tax on tax in the form of
capital gains tax to the government on
money you took the risk on investing all
this usually to impress a woman enough
to commit to you that has already shared
her body with dozens of other men that
brings Baggers to the table that if you
live with or Mary can take half your
[__] your kids if she changes the Mind
changes her mind about you later on down
the road
this is kind of a sad reality that
nobody argued with us and
I you know I figured that I just table
this like what did you guys think of
that
pre-covered I would have said it was
conspiracy now I'm like it's reality
and like I didn't even talk about
everything that was like you know I
tried to keep a condensed there's a lot
more you could insert in there that that
you know amplifies the BS but
people just continue going on with their
day they get up they put gas in their
car they drive they you know they go to
the grocery store they pay their taxes
on income they've already paid taxes on
it's you know it's surprising that they
got to this point isn't it
uh I mean it's like
it you want to say yes when you look at
it from that like you know 30 000 foot
view but then like when you get down
like more ground floor you it's kind of
weird where it's like if people didn't
do that what's how would Society look
would we still have what would it
function right it's really interesting
when you ask that question and the other
thing too is that yeah it sucks but I
mean like at least I'm not working in a
coal mine I have all my fingers
those pyramids were built by somebody
and they probably weren't paid to do it
right so I mean it's kind of always
sucked for people for men especially I
think only in the last maybe 200 years
did not not just like with people in
general got the right to even Vote or
have some semblance of control over
their lives before it was only a few
Elite that ruled everybody yeah it's
almost like that like
the shackles that we've had have been
made invisible so you know follow me
through in this like you know Big Block
was just talking about the guys that
built the Pyramid and we're probably not
paid to build them by the way
um
they they likely saw the shackles on
their ankles you know while they were
doing the work you know slaves you know
a couple hundred years ago saw the
shackles on their ankles the uh you know
the human traded uh Gladiators in you
know the Roman days that were also
slaves also you know saw the binds that
like sort of held them in in place today
they've almost made them invisible it's
like taxation
and the systems that are put in place
yeah with control in that you don't see
them but they exist well the other
Hardware too is we're like cat cattle
yeah we're basically livestock making
tax payments and keeping them
they just can't yeah
we say who times have never been better
we've never been safer but yeah
yeah we're trading our freedoms and
everything for that as well though we
have like we're living in more and more
narrow cages here as far as the things
that we can and can't do with our lives
as well yeah and I mean it's I think
yeah there's no escaping yes right right
there's no escaping it but it's also
interesting it's um you know I think for
you know the fundamental question that
we have right is always do we want a
society that has high security and like
you know lower Freedom or do you want
more freedoms with less security right
and I think people are more and more
willing to give up a lot of their
freedom for at least some even if it's
even if it's imagined right some
semblance of actual
um security right because I mean that's
what you know happened in 2020 where hey
we've got this unprecedented Global
event and everyone went along with hey
we want to feel secure so absolutely we
are we will give up all of our even if
it saves One Life we'll give our freedom
to for that feeling of security and so
that that right there just shows you
like how willing people are to just go
down the pathway
I think it's you know freedom is a true
freedom is it's kind of terrifying and
it takes a lot of like responsibility
and accountability which is
extremely extremely difficult there's
always been Elite sort of pulling your
strings haven't there you know
throughout history whether it was Kings
or Emperors or yeah whoever it happened
to be in the past a thousand years ago
there's always been Elites it's just
they sort of give you the illusion of
Freedom today and you know
maneuverability and that sort of stuff
but
I mean like the whole taxation point is
is just the funniest part of it because
money has no real inherent value it it
only has value because people agree that
it's that it has value like if you hold
up a 20 Greenback everybody that looks
at it will say yeah that's worth 20
bucks and you give that to a [__]
Toucan Sam or a monkey or a gorilla
they'll look at it and they'll wipe
their ass with it it has absolutely no
value because they all agree they don't
know what it is and it has no value so
let me reason what the pride exists
because we all agree that there's value
in it and they keep printing it it's you
know there's an unlimited Supply and
again you know it always brings me back
to the question if they can print an
unlimited supply of this stuff then why
do they tax us with it
[Laughter]
is the power to control but there was a
tweet that went viral as well um this
week Rich I'll try and dig it up but
well 50 when they taxed you like a
thousand years ago when you lived on the
king's land you actually handed him
something of some value that couldn't be
reproduced at a thin air like paper
money right yeah so and it's easier to
increase taxes when people can't
actually see some physical value you got
something in return like you had your
safety you know there was an Army that
would protect you from Advanced forces
but right one of the reasons why they're
so hell-bent on attacking and
controlling let's say the United States
and North America is the entrepreneurial
Spirit over here and there was a viral
tweet from the German lady this week and
it was essentially she said when you're
in Europe and I can attest to this and
she said in Germany when you're born
rich you stay rich and when you're
middle class you can work and you can
get a couple of nice things but she said
damn I've come here I've done this I've
worked my my butt off and she says now I
own a company and she was just on about
how hard that would have been to do back
in Europe and the Testament to that as
they said it was in New York the other
day and about 18 years ago I was giving
this electrician work when I was with a
large general contractor I was like
giving him a 50 000 contract I spoke to
him yesterday he's got 500 employees now
and that's that's how big he's become in
in in almost two decades it's yeah it
blows my mind
like Eastern Europe
is
the remaining place where you can still
create a lot of wealth in within Europe
right the way that the the the laws the
tax structure
the society is um
organized in Western Europe makes it
very hard
to go up the ladder much harder than
even in the U.S or Canada
yeah and they have these these stupid
stupid rules like in France if you have
over an um a certain number of employees
you have to have
um what's it called
um
Syndicate now um
Union
and the union has to have a
representative of the on the members of
the board
and it's like unbelievable so that makes
it very hard for companies to grow it
makes it very hard for people to create
value
um actually I just I was just looking at
the stock market do you know that the
entire tax the top 40 German companies
together added have a smaller market cap
than Apple
will not be surprised to see I connect
that company I can attest to what dragos
just said my body does he does Audio
Visual and he does it on on yachts and
high net worth individual yacht and they
go out to sea obviously and you know the
the sea environment degrade stuff pretty
quickly so he's got to repair the sound
systems and the audio visual systems on
deck and he does uh he does this for an
Irish musician who happens to have his
yacht in the south of France and it pays
this guy to bring his yacht out of the
French Waters drop anchor and fly my
buddy in from New York because the the
guy that does all the repairs in France
he can't hire kids for the summer
because if he hire someone for the
summer he's got to give him a job for
life under you know under French the
guys just look I need some teenagers for
the summer to help me rewire stuff he
can't do it sort of guy you know pulls
his yard off the out of French territory
of waters drops an anchor and my buddy
comes in repairs the thing and back and
he goes and the rest of the guy is there
in Monte Carlo or wherever the heck they
are are Santa pay are waiting for six
months for the local AV guy to get it
there yet
um
yeah there's a little bit about cultural
um like the cultural attitudes right
because of my my friends in Italy right
every time we hang out and talk and
they're always like yeah you Americans
are really interesting because you guys
are very optimistic but you always like
can like reinvent yourselves it's like
we have until we're basically 27 28 and
if we don't have a solid career locked
in we're essentially written off as
social outcasts and failures and so it's
uh the cultural differences are also
really interestingly different uh
between more of the Western European
side and the the United States
yeah and this is why Eastern Europe
absolutely rocks like you get a lot of
value being created now Poland has a lot
of growth Romania has had a lot of
growth
um a great GDP GDP increase which means
a lot of millionaires being minted
I mean it's not it's still small scale
compared to the US right I think
California has uh yeah if we have the
fifth biggest economy I which I still
don't understand how we have the fifth
biggest economy in the entire world if
we were on our own economy like that's
that to me is like in seeing how like
mismanaged a lot of stuff has been in
California I'm just like how we how
we've like lucked our way into it I that
still just makes me wonder like how
how is that even possible like but again
it must be on the tech though well Tech
is a huge apartment but we also have a
huge amount of efforts throughout here
like 80 of the rolls almonds are made in
California uh but we also have a lot of
aircraft industry
um we we have a lot of different
Industries here obviously you know
Hollywood entertainment music all that
type of stuff
um we've got a lot of that as well and
then uh you know definitely some
military uh manufacturing as well but
yeah California is a really really
really like as an economic power they've
they've got a pretty massive economy and
you know you wrote that in with the the
us we just have a really good geography
right like this was literally the most
one of the most perfect places on the
planet you could have like carved out to
make yourself like a geopolitical
superpower because you have really
really great geography it's also really
great against like you know any type of
invasion or anything like that it's like
to try and do a physical land grab
um and then yeah we have a great economy
and uh we have a very stable government
right so those are kind of like the big
things that you need to really be become
a you know true superpower that can you
know have an Empire I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out